that was actually really
comfortable people are climbing into
devices like this one in search of
shorter recovery times and to live
longer healthier lives hyperbaric oxygen
therapy or hbot has gone from Niche
medical treatment in hospitals to a
wellness Trend that wealthy athletes
celebrities and biohackers are opening
their wallets to try the chambers are
pressurized so you breathe in more
oxygen with a goal of making your body
more efficient so does oxygen therapy
actually work and does it live up to the
hype see you soon
oxygen therapy is going mainstream
everything from oxygen bars to Portable
inhalers fancy spas and at home Chambers
the chambers come in a variety of shapes
sizes and price tags The increased
demand comes thanks to tantalizing
papers like this one the study looks at
the health benefits of hyperbaric oxygen
therapy or hbot we are actually taking
the biology back in time Hyperbaric just
means higher pressure than normal in
this study there were two key findings
that suggested that some signs of aging
had been been reversed longer telam and
a reduction of malfunctioning cells
telam are like molecular safety helmets
for DNA and as our cells age and divide
these caps get shorter compromising the
stability of genes which makes for
unstable cells and those unstable cells
are more prone to turn cancerous or die
in Shai's study participants spend 90
minutes in Chambers like this one every
day for 60 days and it's team found that
the proportion of malfunctioning immune
system cells went down by a few
percentage points after treatment
compared to before that's important
because as we age our cognitive
abilities heart health and the ability
to fight infections decline in part
because the cells which make up our
organs start to get sick and die age
related functional decline this is the
biggest Hazard that our society have but
Shai said his findings are specific to
the way he conducted his study with that
in mind I went to a different clinic in
New Jersey to check out how other hbot
treatments work so here this is our
Hyperbaric area and environment of
increased pressure and an environment of
increased oxygen oxygen is a critical
nutrient that keeps our cells and our
bodies running the air we breathe is
about 20% oxygen whether you're at sea
level or high altitudes but the higher
you go the less pressure there is and
the more dispers the oxygen molecules
become a hyperic chamber uses pressure
to compress air similar to what happens
when you fly an airplane is basically a
giant hyperbaric chamber right it's a
pressurized cabin to show that
compression Jason got into a chamber
with an inflated balloon as the pressure
went up the balloon shrank the air and
the oxygen it contained was being
concentrated so if I were actually doing
this session I would mask up and then
you would close the door for me y okay
most oxygen Chambers in hospitals go up
to about 2 to three times of pressure at
sea level the person then breathes
through mask like these instead of the
20% in normal air The Mask delivers a
100% oxygen from these tanks Shai told
me that together with the high pressure
in the tank the m mask helps deliver 16
times as much oxygen into the blood and
then to the muscles and organs that
increases the amount of oxygen available
to fuel the body compared to the 1970s
there's now a lot more hospitals
providing hbot but using hyperbaric
oxygen therapeutically goes back more
than a 100 years with doctors trying to
help divers get over the bend AKA
decompression sickness this happens when
divers come up to the surface too fast
to show what that might look like Jason
blew up a second balloon while he was in
the chamber at High pressure now imagine
your lungs are the balloon as the
chamber returns to sea level in worst
case scenario your lungs could right now
there are only 13 other scenarios where
insurance will pay for agbot and those
are also the only ones you'd be able to
get treated for at a hospital at the
cellular level higher oxygen intake
increases oxygen delivery to deprived
areas when someone has the bend it also
helps prevent further damage by reducing
inflammation and hopefully speed up the
healing process in animal studies h
hyperbaric oxygen therapy increased the
growth of new blood vessels and some of
Shai's work show similar effects in
humans results like these plus all the
social media hype have made oxygen
therapy super popular people are
installing tanks in their homes or going
to clinics seeking the health benefits I
mentioned earlier obiously we have three
hard Chambers where we're using
hyperbaric oxygen to help improve
healing and recovery and regeneration
for all kinds of different patients
obviously there's a door these valves
give us basically the pressure that
we're going to be going to that gauge is
what tells us where we are okay and then
these are just tools to control the flow
of oxygen and the flow of air coming in
and out clinics can administer hbot off
label meaning at a clinician's
discretion that's not regulated by the
FDA the treatment also varies from
location to location depending on the
equipment and the amount of pressure
that's used in Jason's chamber patients
breathe in 100% oxygen continuously at
Shai a thie clinics they take off the
mask every couple of minutes he says
that tricks the body into thinking it
sted for oxygen meaning all the repair
mechanism are starting to be activated
and that's supposed to build your body's
resilience toward aging it's unclear
whether and under what conditions hbot
has lasting effects the truth is a lot
of the questions people ask the answer
is we don't know yet as with any
procedure hpot carries known risks
medical doctors I spoke to said that
people who have epilepsy COPD or empyema
shouldn't use hyperbaric oxygen therapy
at very high pressures because it could
be dangerous there are Al less serious
side effects like temporary vision
changes Li headedness claustrophobia
vomiting and ear damage soft Chambers
people install at home are pumped with
room air so the quality of the air you
breathe is harder to track experts say
that most heart chambers are installed
in Hospitals and Clinics but there have
been reports of hard Chambers exploding
in people's homes in these videos I
usually try out these therapies for
myself but after talking to my doctor I
decided against it but if you decide to
try it make sure to speak to a trained
Medical Professional before getting into
any chamber if you want to treat
yourself do it right don't play the
overarching advice I got was don't try
this at home especially by
yourself